what's up guys big movie weekend World
War Z and Monsters Inc and that got us
thinking what's the scariest movie
monster we brought in the experts to
tell us kids hi how's it going great so
Amanda let me ask you a question our
monster is real or fake fake I think
they're actually red real monsters are
fake even though they're fake are some
monsters scary yes are there any real
monsters in the world well I think
ghosts oh yeah Mia my friends have a
ghost Club Wow did you find any real
ghosts yeah
our schools mostly the haunted this
place in the world what what's the
scariest monster you can think of it's
Bloody Mary say Bloody Mary three times
Bloody Mary Bloody Mary Bloody Mary what
the heck are you doing now she's gonna
show up to celebrate monsters University
the sequel to Monsters Inc we're gonna
show you some monsters and we want you
to tell us which one's the scariest okay
all right put that thing back where it
came from one so help me I watched that
movie before yes s Myka Sulley are they
scary not aliens me see it's all okay
that's good enough for me who's that
Cookie Monster that's the Cookie Monster
right and he likes to eat sushi no I'm
just kidding Oh what's the most cookies
you ever ate at once Oh
gaku chip okay that wasn't really the
question what does Cookie Monster eat
all you just cookies all eats is cookies
yeah he should be dead by now right
oh no you know how much Cookie Monster
loves cookies yeah that's how much my
dad likes beers
pretty cool right not that cool who's
that oh that's got to how scary is he I
think one wouldn't like that but I don't
think he's scary he does what you think
woman wouldn't like that yeah
Oh our women easily more easily scared
than men women are yeah yeah women are
more scared than read oh that's just
creepy oh yeah I have seen this is it
scary again to woman but not to me you
got a lot of machismo there buddy mm-hmm
what about this monster have you heard
of Twilight yes my friend Alicia watched
it she's only um I think eight your
friend Alicia has terrible parents
that's okay they're probably nice
does he look anything like a shovel to
you know like what if a shovel and a
face had a baby
yeah Cuyuna who's scarier him or Dracula
him why is he scarier than Dracula cuz
he had hair on his chest and it looked
like he was turning into a werewolf I
mean it's got like peach fuzz barely a
man
I ate his liver with some fava beans
nice yeah you know II ate somebody what
kind of monster is he he's a bad guy
well he doesn't look scary did your
parents ever show you silence for the
Lambs no what are you gonna ask them to
show you silence of the lambs great who
I love yes a big shark kind of going
like eat you like oh is that from Jaws
is that scary
the shark no the boat yeah the shark
yeah he looked like like you the little
tiger master hey hold up a second what
is a China master if you live in China
just like this little master are you
saying that Chinese people look like
that he doesn't look like that it just
looked like kiss your skin is your dog
oh so he looks like a Chinese person
with no skin yeah okay
oh is that a transformer and it kind of
looks like my dog except no eyes what
kind of dog do you have like a skinless
monster dog please don't show me that
again okay but let's watch it again oh
that's creepy yeah Arnold Schwarzenegger
there he got his housekeeper pregnant
what don't worry about it oh oh no is
that from the movie alien
oh yeah he's scarier that's the scariest
so far jumped a little I did well I'm
not scared of the monster I'd be scared
if I got Aiden who's Aiden okay everyone
that's the Cloverfield monster you a fan
of JJ Abrams no I'm Bank Justin Bieber
oh yeah I am Weezy it's a clown is he
scary No
oh yeah
what do you think about that
I like clowns who'd win in a fight this
this clown monster or your dad
clown monster what about me or the clown
monster clown monster what about me or
your dad yeah yeah really
hmm oh my dad's weak well that was scary
you think we gave those kids nightmares
what do you think the scariest movie of
all time is what's the scariest movie
monster leave an answer in the comments
below best answer got the screen doggies
t-shirt why thanks again for watching
guys I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye